[Applause]  oh greatest of kings  indulge me in this friendly christmas  game  let whichever of your nights his boldest  blood and wildest of hearts step forth  take up arms and try with honor to land  a blow against me  whomsoever nicks me shall lay claim to  this my arm  its glory and riches shall be mine  but  thy champ must bind himself to this  should he land a blow then one year and  yuletide hence  he must seek me out yonder to the green  chapel  six nights to the north he shall find me  there and bend a knee and let me strike  him in return  be it a scratch on the check or a cut in  the throat  i will return what was given to me and  then in trust and friendship we shall  part  who then who is willing to engage with  me  queen  [Music]  [Music]  you